>> Our CNN primetime exclusive
interview with the president of
Ukraine continues right now
with the biggest question of
all, how does this wherever and?
As you know the United States
have been warning China against
providing lethal weapons to
Russia.
Have you been briefed, mister
president, recently by U.S.
Officials on where this all
stands?
Do you expect China to take
that step?
>> Translator: I would like to
have all the countries support
the end of the war.
And on the side of all other
security directions, which we
have lack of, and we are
interested to have China on the
side of the nuclear safety and
security.
The U.S. Does not have much --
we understand that, and how the
U.S. Will be living with China,
it is a matter between the U.S.
And China.
But when the war starts in the
European continent which is
happening today in Ukraine, we
have to be interested in
limiting this war and ending
this war.
That is why this factor should
unite us.
Russia is an aggressor.
Russia should not be on the
sovereign Ukrainian territory.
It should go away, not with
force but to retreat itself, to
respecting the international
law.
It shouldn't be occupying the
nuclear power plants because it
is a threat to the whole of the
world.
I'm talking about zaporizhzhia
power plants.
That is the risk, and other
countries --
all of them, despite the
geopolitical differences, we
have to be interested in peace.
From the it's offering T to the
territorial integrity to the
end of this war.
>> Under what conditions would
you be willing to speak
directly with Vladimir Putin?
>> Translator: And I think that
today we don't have any
circumstances to talk to the
Russian president because he
doesn't hold his word.
We don't have any confidence in
him.
And he killed thousands of
people in order to discuss
resolution of war as a whole,
and configuration of this
diplomatic decision.
Not military, but diplomatic
decision in order to do that,
Russia should leave our
territory.
After that, we have to join the
diplomatic battles in order to
do that.
We can find any format with our
partners just after that.
>> What does the endgame,
mister president, look like?
How do you define victory in
this war?
>> Translator: We will have
victory.
I think that victory we'll end
up with the understandable
security decisions for many
years to come, and I am sure
after this war there will be
more understandable situations
in the European continent and
more stable situations on the
European continent, and Russia
will not be able to threaten
any other countries fighting
for their freedom and
Independence.
If Russia's troops will not
leave Ukrainian territory, war
will be raging in Ukraine, in
Europe, on and on, that is why
at any point, there will be
another war which will lead to
the third World War and we
totally understand that.
Number one, they have to leave
Ukraine.
They should either be pushed
out of Ukrainian territory or
negotiate an agreement with
other partners.
They have to leave our
territory and then only then we
can talk about diplomacy.
Now, we have to say if we will
leave it it will be calm before
another storm.
>> Do you believe, mister
president, that Ukraine can win
this war this year, 2023?
>> Translator: It all depends
on the speed of the supply of
material and military support.
The longer it will take, the
less motivation the fighters
will be without any supplies of
weaponry.
That is why the motivation will
evade because if we don't give
people weapons they cannot go
into a fence and if you wait,
if you wait and wait, the
victory will come later.
But I am not doubting this
victory.
It only depends on time.
>> President zelenskyy gets
personal in a moment when I
asked him about his children,
and what it is like to raise
them in this time of extreme